you might have noticed there has been
quite a steady stream of policies
announced by all the parties during this
election as you expect
but for voters who will have to make a
choice in just a few weeks time it's
quite tricky to know where exactly the
impact of some of those quite expensive
policies would be what for example are
they going to mean for businesses that
employ people up and down the country
and to try and give us an insight into
that we're joined now by the
director-general of the Confederation of
British industry count that and thank
you very much for being in the studio
with us good morning
today so what do businesses want to see
the next government prioritize well this
is an extraordinary election for
business next year will be the most
important year I think in a generation
because we've seen so much uncertainty
investment plans put on hold so we are
looking from the next government to
really unlock this and I think three
things Sophie are most important first
of all yes there's brexit but we must
get back to the long term challenges
facing our economy around how we build
skills for the future how we do really
tackle climate change and inequality
that massive question of fairness and
this has to be a partnership between
business and government so we're looking
for that a resetting of that partnership
we're also looking to get back to
competitiveness the economy has suffered
through through lack of decision making
but we need to look at the cost base and
we need to look at our immigration
policy to make sure that that works for
business and we do need to build those
infrastructure projects that have been
put on hold like hs2 and Heathrow
absolutely fundamental signal they'll be
open to the world and finally of course
getting the right brexit deal
frictionless trade for for our economy
and also a great deal for our services
so a really important election are
really important set of policies to get
our economy moving again and what do you
make us on the policy announcements so
far and for example this morning you've
laid out what they want to see happen
with immigration so we've seen some just
to take the the Conservatives some good
announcements on digital some good
announcements on investment the
immigration policy I mean I think one of
the things that we absolutely recognize
are the things will need to change a
public trust does have to be rebuilt but
it has to be done in a way that works
for the economy so when we hear told
this way when we hear talk about
brightest and best I think that is they
worry you know if you do want to build
200,000 houses a year you don't just
need the architects and the designers
you need the carpenters you need the
electricians you need the laborers we
need people to come and help us renew
our economy so we'll have to look at the
detail it has to be manageable by small
business the previous visa system was
extremely costly and less than 1% of
businesses were using it so the devil
will be in the detail but it's not just
brightest and best it's people at all
skill levels across our economy that we
need and it's staying with the
Conservatives for the moment as well and
another feature this campaign has been
Boris Johnson ruling out any extension
to the transition if he is Prime
Minister which is not very long to
strike a trade deal to be frank it's a
worry for you well one of the things I
think it's really important to
understand is if you are a business
living through the last three years
these rolling cliff edges of climbing up
a mountain with with stockpiling and
then climbing down again could not be
more damaging so I think one of our
messages to the next government who may
be negotiating at this deal is don't box
yourself in don't set new automations
and
and this time create enough time to
ensure we can get a good deal for our
economy the right kind of deal think so
is it got to send you to Southend do you
worry well we have to watch the detail I
mean I think when we come back in the
New Year and may be in a position of
negotiating a new deal the first it
needs to happen you get the right
architecture with business so that we
have proper evidence-based policy for
that new trade deal and let's make sure
that we don't end up with yet another
cliff edge possibly in June or possibly
at the end of December because every
time we do that we take investment away
from our country and let's move on to
labour shall we and is Jeremy Corbyn a
friend to business well we really
understand the questions that Labour are
asking they are asking questions about
about inequality they are asking
questions about public services these
are the right ones but we look at the
policies on the table and we have real
concerns that they are going to crack
the foundations of our economy you look
at something like the
zatia program the biggest on record the
the fact that we now have a bolt from
the blue
in terms of bt nationalization that will
freeze investment I have talked to
businesses who are already sitting there
thinking and maybe we're next
so we do say again to labor work with
business work out different answers to
these problems but this program that is
appearing to value none of the
contribution that business makes will
simply shut investments out of our cab
what does that mean
freezing investment is that job losses
well what is it well it at the moment it
means some of the really interesting
investments going on hope you've already
heard that in broadband right you know
immediately the announcement had made by
labor some very important investments in
for fibre broadband have been put on on
hold and we need to remember that
investment today is jobs of the future
so absolutely and it's also freezing
those things that we need to create
product productivity in our economy
which has been such a crisis for our
country it's felt like we've had quite a
high spending election campaign so far
I mean austerity is out of the window
you know that the spending caps are well
and truly back on is that a good thing
is that what the economy needs or are
you worried that now you know fiscal
responsibilities a bit of a dirty phrase
well we do need investment it's
absolutely right look at our creaking
infrastructure and you look at the
investment we need in skills but we'd
say do that in partnership with business
and make sure that these plans are
sustainable in terms of our economy we
don't want to get back to a place where
we are overspending so again the
partnership with business you know we've
got some extraordinary success stories
recently looked at renewables energy and
offshore wind prices have come down
there in where's no one thought was
possible that's private sector
investment working with government so be
very careful about excessive spending
pleasures yeah I think it's interesting
listen to hear talk about working with
business because it felt like there was
a time in politics when people who
wanted to be Prime Minister we're really
keen to work with big business Tony
Blair David Cameron and now it's kind of
got a bit out of vogue do you think that
some are almost seeing big businesses
the enemy well I really really
not I mean I think it's been it has been
a challenging period in terms of
business working with government I think
we can't deny that but we have also seen
that in terms of some of these
announcements that we've seen they are
exactly what business needs in terms of
the digital infrastructure and in terms
of investment in skills so that
conversation needs to continue but as I
say what we do hope is that there will
now be a reset that there is an
opportunity I think to do some
extraordinary things if we work more
closely together
climate change is another example but
it's not some would say that big
business perhaps part of the problem and
not the solution
I really don't accept that I think all
businesses are part of the solution our
big businesses many of them are the most
productive in the UK created fantastic
high quality jobs working with small
businesses in their supply chains we
need to work together business is not
perfect we know that there are ways that
they can improve but they our businesses
employ 27 million people they invest
they innovate they are a huge part of
the solution and we need the best
possible partnership of the government
to make that happen okay thank you very
much for being on the program today
appreciate just Caroline programming
from the CBI